was für ein netter sensation hier eben
mitten in hessen das heißt bei der
nächsten gästen sind genau die beiden
alkohol und oberen locker nochmal genau
die lobbys und wir reden über über
wasser marsch über alles youtube über
die videos ist unser leben und unser
anfang und silber unser leben also weil
es halt über alles reden über alles was
euch nehmen kein blatt vor den mund und
auch wenn es um eure fragen geht das
heißt klickt in die kommentare also
schreibt kommentar wird
und wenn er ins kommentarfeld klickt
dann erscheint daneben der button wieder
an bord hochladen das kreis ihr könnt
auch fragen bei video stellt das lied ja
sowieso sogar am meisten und welche
fragen wenn euch also ganz auf rettungs
fragen gestellt seitdem single habt ihr
eine freundin warum habt ihr mit youtube
angefangen was gibt es noch die hofft ja
so was heißt also was einmal bitte nur
fragen wer dass einer schon hochgeladen
hat könnte das las und dann andere
fragen und ansonsten achtung 83 21
bis dann bleibt dran